[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
do you want to go deeper on all of the
games that have been featured in today's
live show well of course you do
otherwise why would you be here waiting
for the live event to start well you
know what friend you've got just enough
time to go over and consider joining the
fgs YouTube and Tick Tock Pages where
you can watch all of the trailers from
each and every show that we do not to
forget you'll also get exclusive game
developer chats you'll be able to see
previews on demos that will be available
right after the show itself and you'll
get daily gaming content from the rest
of the fgs team and speaking of which
I'm Jules one of the presenters on the
fgs team and you can come watch me gab
about my favorite games Maya least
favorite games and everything in between
including some live streams as well all
you've got to do right now is Type in
fgs on Tick Tock or YouTube and go and
consider subscribing to both of our
social platforms and hopefully if you do
we'll see you in the very near future
but until then enjoy the show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey everybody it's me Yuri I play Peter
Parker in Marvel Spider-Man exciting
isn't it the old build up
we've got around 10 minutes till show
time but I've just been looking through
the scripts
so much ground to cover but it's gonna
be awesome we've got new trailers for
stray Gods layers of fear Life by you
Lords of the fallen and Pacific drive
but that's enough teasing we'll get to
it in the main show stay tuned and we'll
see you in a second
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hey oh good to see you all I hope you're
ready for this we have about five
minutes until show time so I need to go
find Yuri I just checked my script
though and this show is packed let me
give you a little sneak peek there's
trailers from Lords of the Fallen layers
of fear instinction firewall Ultra Life
by you
basically you're gonna want to stick
around anyway I gotta go I gotta go get
ready we'll see you at five
[Music]
oh
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Laura Bailey though you
may know me best as the voice of Abby in
The Last of Us Part Two Mary Jane Watson
and Marvel Spider-Man or maybe even the
host of the June 2021 future game show
and now I am back and this time on a
super cool stage to host this year's
future game show summer showcase
presented by Intel but as we all know
with great power comes great
responsibility and thankfully I've got
Yuri here to share it with me I'm so
glad we got that out of the way since
okay thanks Laura it's great to be here
I'm Yuri lowenthal and I'm the voice of
Sasuke on Naruto yosuke and Persona 4
and of course Peter Parker in Marvel
Spider-Man but tonight I'm swapping out
the Spidey suit for something a little
more Suave think less thrips more quips
actually just like Spider-Man exactly
Yuri and I have been on Plenty of
Adventures like when we explored the
midnight Channel with a talking teddy
bear or when we brought down Mr negative
right we have the best I know but let me
tell you nothing prepares you for a
stacked showcase full of video game news
you're telling me now I've had a sneaky
little look at what's to come we've got
demo drops developer presentations
gameplay trailers montages and of course
world premieres nice thank you wishlist
at the ready folks and remember if
something catches your eye during the
show head to gamesradar.com to read more
about it I think we've covered all the
bases so let's kick things off of
something really special please welcome
Tamara yokic and gilad Baraka who are
here to deliver a very special
performance of waves from Beyond from
the soundtrack to high water
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
see
she knows
[Music]
who's there
is
[Music]
foreign
well that was beautiful thanks again to
Tamara and gilad high water was
previously available on Netflix but
today we are pleased to reveal that it's
coming to PC PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and S and Nintendo switch in the summer
make sure to wish listed on Steam all
right before we get to our first world
premiere we've got a quick update during
this year's Spring Showcase we announced
that the world of future game show is
expanding with the launch of the new fgs
YouTube and Tick Tock channels and after
we wrap up today you'll be able to go
deeper into selected games from the show
with exciting videos from the growing
fgs editorial team search for fgs on
YouTube or Tick Tock and look out for
the Channel logo you can see behind us
all right let's keep this engine running
I think it's time for our very first
world premiere
thank you
so
why are we really doing this
I thought you hated racing I need to get
into the city again who is going to walk
away with this year's City Pass tune in
and find out it's going to be one hell
of a ride
how's everyone enjoying the show he
can't be allowed to keep doing this but
how can we stop him
by playing him at his own game
thank you
Esther what would you like to say to all
your fans
[Music]
welcome to the world of resistor a
post-apocalyptic car PG where you build
a ragtag team of racers it's coming soon
to PC Playstation Xbox and Nintendo
switch so get it on your wish lists
what's next Yuri well here we go from
the post-apocalyptic to the prehistoric
it's dinosaurs my favorite part of the
day let's see it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you're good to go
I don't know I think I'd kind of enjoy
being stuck in an Intergalactic traffic
jam if the views were that good right I
mean I get the whole truck Sim thing now
looks strangely relaxing that was your
first Glimpse at Star trucker which is
coming in 2024. but now it's time to
shift gears to demon gods and Dark
Fantasy we've got a developer
presentation from hexworks the minds
behind Lords of the Fallen
thank you
on behalf of hexworks Welcome to the
Lords of the Fallen gameplay showcase
today we're taking a closer look at our
all-new dark fantasy action RPG arriving
this October on PC PS5 and Xbox series
xns
[Music]
spiritual successor to the original 2014
release it acts as a full reboot for the
franchise taking place in a vast
interconnected world over a thousand
years later
featuring colossal boss battles fast
challenging combat and deep immersive
storytelling players will journey across
two parallel Realms in this expansive
RPG experience the world of the living
Axiom and the world of the Dead
Umbro with each featuring its own unique
Pathways characters enemies and of
course Treasures
and while Axiom presents its own
challenges Untold Horrors await in its
nightmarish counterpart
thanks to the umbral lamp players can
enter this flightless world at any time
in one of two ways when slain by the
foes of Axiom at which point you'll
resurrect in the same location albeit in
umbral
or by performing The umbral Rift
unwillingly sacrificing one of your two
lives
but the lamb holds yet more power
granting the ability to Flay the soul
from an enemy for some high damage
attacks and even manipulate the very
environment of the umbral world
however the longer you spend in this
wraith-ridden plane the greater number
of spectral Terrors that will hunt you
down
as harrowing as the hellions of
umbrellar they pale in comparison to the
game's brutal boss battles
towering above the ever burning city of
kalrath the Garden can't you in
monstrosity doesn't take kindly to would
be adventurers the Demonic presence
within ready to devour any and all
within sight
in merciless torturer prepared to carry
out any atrocity in the name of his
faith Tankard master of castigations is
The Devout chaplain of the hallowed
Sentinels though beneath the pious fail
his very own flesh conceals a truth most
powerful
when Harrow or Darva ventured into the
deepest depths of this world to thwart
the undead Rising what she discovered
was so utterly horrific that she
renounced her former life and commitment
to a far darker oath
pre-order Lords of the Fallen now and
prepare to unleash the darkness on
Friday the 13th of October
[Music]
Lords of the Fallen is coming to PC
PlayStation and Xbox on October 13 2023
and you can wish list it right now
wait what what is it here are you okay
spidey sense is tingling
oh no wait it's something good it's time
for another world premiere
oh
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hey King
[Music]
being 17.
that was so infectious yeah yeah that is
going to be in my head for a while I
think well you know I really can't
complain watch out for Headbangers
Rhythm Royale which is coming to PC
Playstation Xbox and Nintendo switch in
2023. so what's next Laura oh well this
game debuted as a world premiere in last
year's summer showcase and now we've got
a closer look at gameplay this is the
last face which some fans are describing
as a pixelated take on bloodborne a
hunter's dream you might say
a new dawn is at hand
secret has been snatched
in the hands of the sword
but one rises above all others
blessed curse the sweetness of the flame
thank you
be inevitable can be for them now
death
thank you
[Music]
that was the last Faith a Gothic Souls
like coming to PC Playstation Xbox and
Nintendo switch in October 2023 and you
can wish list it right now on Steam
we're also thrilled to announce that the
last faith will have a beta demo this
summer if you want to check it out
register for access at
thelastfaithgame.com
our next game is a stealth Action
platformer set in the wake of a climate
catastrophe let's take a trip to the
world of Steel seed
foreign
and I'm the founder and game director of
stormi natica
let me introduce you to wincobee the
dynamic duo that will accompany you
during your journey
today we are excited to show you the
gameplay reveal of Steel scene
seed is
a complex and large driven spot
after a major climate catastrophe caused
by humans the AIS took control of the
situation in order to find a way to
preserve life
Zoe is looking for a father in an
underground facility built by machines
an extremely hostile tour of the novice
environment surrounding Zoe is huge and
takes heavy inspiration from popular
mangas movies and anime
Zoe needs Kobe to work with exploration
environment interaction stealth and
combat their bond will grow stronger the
more challenges they will face together
facing enemies without using Kobe is
extremely dangerous
the planning phase using your companion
is essential
sometimes a start approach in
problematic scenarios is preferable
and a good execution will be highly
rewarding
the environment will offer you many ways
to deal with enemies
be the Silent Assassin
you feel more aggressive or if you screw
up the stealth approach a fast-paced and
tactical combat system will allow you to
Unleash Your combat abilities on the
enemies
don't forget the Cub is there to help
you with ranged attacks and skills your
companion really makes the difference
between life and death
if you still feel underpowered a complex
Skill 3 system based on challenges will
allow you to expand Zoe and copies
passive and active abilities
the challenge system is designed to
render The Experience more Dynamic and
fun
also in dangerous times you may require
dangerous friends
use Kobe to work into an enemy system to
make it fight with you your new ally
will create hilariously engaging combat
scenarios
there are many more abilities that you
can unlock from the skills people Choose
Wisely
thanks for your time with us
steel seed is a truly emotional
experience that will test your inner
Humanity
the game is coming to PC Microsoft Xbox
and Sony PlayStation
stay tuned
[Music]
steel seed is coming soon to PC
PlayStation and Xbox man I gotta say
voice acting is so much easier when
you're not wearing a skin tight suit am
I right wait a second are you telling me
you wear the Spidey suit when you record
me no
we need to talk after this but right now
we've got a double feature focusing on
distant Bloom and go fight fantastic
let's get into it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
mission to a peaceful Planet huh
nothing's ever routine with this crew
but one thing's for sure we'll deal with
whatever comes
together
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
distant Bloom and go fight fantastic are
coming later this year so head on over
to steam and flesh out your quickly
growing wish lists and here's a bonus
limited time demos for both games have
also been made available on Steam so
head on over to the Future game show
steam page if you want to check them out
Laura oh God wait what what's happening
oh sorry I was reading too far ahead
it's World premiere time again
this is the last time she runs my plan
find her and bring her to me a challenge
I like that
[Music]
let's finish this
maybe next time
come Duke stop this nonsense now
Paul Amigo try to fight me at least
[Music]
on guard
am I the only one who's never heard of
her
that was unguiled a swashbuckling action
adventure which is coming in the summer
of 2023 wishlist it now on Steam hey
Yuri yes when you think of the three
pillars of video games what do you see
okay well for me it's got to be
obviously big rigs big bucks and snow
trucks okay that was not what I was
expecting but boy do I have the trailer
for you I'm ready
thank you
[Music]
Titan that's Rising on just your watch
me this is how Legends are made
[Music]
Alaskan truck simulator is coming to PC
PlayStation and Xbox in Q3 2023 so drop
it on your wish lists now now our next
game follows a scribe who's been
sentenced to 30 years of writer's block
hey we've all been there am I right
let's take a look at the book Walker
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
that reminds me I really should return
those library books I borrowed you
really should those guys are coming
after you the bookwalker thief of tales
is coming to PC Xbox and PlayStation on
June 22nd and you can play a free demo
for the game on Steam after the show
okay here's a new trailer for deceit 2 a
Macabre social subterfuge game built
from the ground up in Unreal Engine 5.
foreign
[Music]
deceit 2 is coming to PC PlayStation and
Xbox in 2023 and you can also play the
beta now and if you like Yay give it a
wish list but of course lying is only
one part of our life for some of us
anyways maybe more our next game
features the rest of it it's time to
check in with Paradox tectonic the
developers of Life by you
hi future game show this is King Choi
Studio director of marketing at Paradox
lit led by you first off I want to share
a heartfelt thank you to The Gaming
Community especially the life simulation
players for your overwhelming response
when we first announced the game back in
March of this year and if you're just
learning about us for the very first
time welcome
Life by you is designed to be one of the
most moddable and open world life
simulation games launching on PC as an
early access title this September Life
by you is opening up a whole new world
of creative possibilities be in total
control of the humans that you create
the towns that you build and the stories
that you tell driven by real language
conversations and most importantly live
out the lives and stories that you
create in a world without loading
screens and oh yes mods we here at
Paradox electronic are continuing to
build off the DNA of great games that
Paradox interactive is known for
especially when it comes to community
focused features and experiences the
Creator tools as well as editors that
you'll be able to play with in our game
will allow you to get your hands on the
same tools that our game team is using
to actually make the game in order to
make your own ugc ad mods
Just for future game show 2023 here's an
exclusive look at one of the jobs that
your characters will be able to take on
in life by you here's my human Harley
heading to her job as the Barista at the
Cozy up Cafe Harley will need to
complete a set of tasks as part of her
workday including cleaning up displays
that customers will inspect and takes
apples from head over to the YouTube
channel at Life by you to learn more
about the game and make sure you
subscribe to be the first to know when
we do our weekly video drops including
feature deep Dives and also depth
streams that we'll be posting in the
coming weeks and months pre-order the
game on Epic and wishlist it on Steam
when you pre-order you'll be able to
receive the exclusive Life Begins pack
and the first hundred thousand Early
Access players will be invited to a
private Discord server where you'll be
able to share direct feedback to our
game team to inform the roadmap and the
development of the game to its full
launch we're so excited for you to get
your hands on this game and thank you so
much for having us future game show 2023
Life by you is coming to steam Early
Access on September 12 2023 so make sure
to wish list it today okay time to
switch things up for a sec the VR
showcase first appeared in our Spring
Showcase earlier this year and now it's
back by popular demand so let's swing
over there and see what's new oh I see
yeah we pretty flip so let's see what's
new in the world of virtual reality
whoa this is all new what do we do any
ideas Yuri
I see a highlighted path so I guess like
any good video game protagonist we
should follow it blindly sounds smart to
me uh ah here's our first game a
reimagining of a Dreamcast cult classic
that lets you play Squash in space let's
check in with C smash vrs
Peg E3
thank you
[Music]
foreign
be mindful of low hanging light fixtures
because see smash vrs is coming to psvr
2 later this month on June 23 2023. if
you haven't got it on your wish list
already fix that would you and if you're
not convinced by that trailer you can
check out a free demo for the game on
the PlayStation Store next up we have
something for those of you looking for a
different way to get your heart pumping
take a look at this trailer for Madison
VR
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yikes even Polaroids are scary now that
was Madison VR which is coming 2023.
forget the elbow and knee pads this next
game lets you shred without the fear of
falling let's see what's new with VR
skater
[Music]
[Applause]
watch out
[Music]
cool stickers VR skater is flipping its
way onto Pico and psvr2 headsets in
2023. now it's time to head over here
and throw it over to First Contact
entertainment who can give us the
lowdown on firewall Ultra a tactical VR
shooter coming exclusively to psvr 2.
hi I'm Frank from first Contact
entertainment and it is our pleasure to
be here at the future game
we've got our heads down for a while now
working on firewall Ultra the next
evolution of the firewall franchise
which is coming exclusively to
PlayStation VR2 in firewall Ultra you'll
be playing as an elite contractor tasked
with either downloading or defending
sensitive information you'll be able to
hop in with a squad of up to three other
players and show off your skills across
varied locations in both our PVP and PVE
modes
the team has been working hard to create
a truly deep and immersive experience
that is a treat for all the senses
we've taken full advantage of the
hardware utilizing eye tracking haptics
in both the controllers and headsets
trigger resistance and the power of the
PlayStation 5 to create something that
truly feels like a generational lead
tour
we can't wait for you to enter the world
of firewall Ultra coming exclusively to
PlayStation VR 2 later this year now
thanks for watching and enjoy the rest
of the show
firewall Ultra is set to launch on psvr
2 later this year last but certainly not
least we've got an exclusive World
premiere of of new VR experience
featuring a famous animated Duo hold on
to your wensley Dale
[Music]
oh what a cracker of a morning
the grand getaway it's a right burst
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
looks cracking Yuri Wallace and Gromit
in the grand getaway is coming to meta
Quest 2 and metaquez Pro in 2023. this
brings us to the end of the VR showcase
we ran out a highlighted path anyway so
I guess we should fast travel does
anyone see any Subway signs around here
anyone hello
okay we're back and I think I've hit my
liminal space quota for today don't
forget to check gamesradar.com and the
fgs social channels for more info on all
of the games from today's future game
shows summer showcase powered by Intel
okay time for some more trailers Yuri
yeah for sure let's pick back up with an
exciting World premiere
[Music]
foreign
where where am I
where do you think this is the ponia
so a nightmare is finally over
if I were you I'd really reconsider that
statement
[Music]
hey you this is Bender from the delic
entertainment and you just watched the
review trailer of our upcoming story
driven Survival game surviving naponia
it has been seven years since we last
visited our lovely trash planet and
illusion the floating city has crashed
down onto its surface and turned it into
a mad Maxine nightmare Master the
environment build your own base and meet
new as well as our Trends in Early
Access 2023
that was surviving deponia a survival
Twist on the cult classic
point-and-click series it's coming soon
so head on over to steam and drop it on
your wish list to stay up to date Dan I
am parched not as parched as the
citizens of our next game who live in a
post-apocalyptic Society where water has
become new gold where have I heard that
before
by yourself all you've got around here
is Desert
choose to band together with others
you've got life
water civilization
survive
you must reach out to the world outside
and the most difficult choice
is always right around the corner
[Music]
homesick is coming to PC on July 20th
2023 so be sure to stick it on your wish
list okay I don't want to alarm anyone
but I can see that we've got yet another
world premiere coming up nextrages how
is this possible how many are we up to
now someone tell me in the chat while we
roll the trailer actually
[Music]
I hear you calling
the wave is blowing
something Lost In Me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
always cool to define a new genre here
at the future game show that was Leica
aged Through Blood the very first
motorvania
that's what I'm calling it and I'm I'm
sticking to it no notes Leica age
through blood is coming to PC
PlayStation Nintendo switch and Xbox in
2023. next let's hand it over to Penta
Peak Studios to dig into the mechanics
of their upcoming strategy game Space
gears
100 years in the future Mars is at War
space garage is a new strategy game
so in the fight
space gears is coming soon to PC but you
can terraform your opinion on it by
playing it for free after the show nice
how about something terrifying though
Bluebird team is sent over the brand new
launch trailer for The Studio's first
person horror game layers of fear
Peggy 16.
[Music]
Talent
prestige
recognition
you took away what was rightfully mine
but what was stolen
can be reclaimed
[Music]
it's been years
and yet
it all still feels unreal
the memories
the nightmares
they've never left this place
[Music]
all right
I've waited too long
it's time
[Music]
what how they
hi Ma darling it is that fuel of course
mom
how's your book going I'm glad to hear
your voice
but how
it's good to have you back writer
[Music]
laughs
no not again
[Music]
and I've wet my pants that was layers of
fear which is coming to PC Mac
PlayStation 5 and Xbox series consoles
on June 15th up next we've got a unique
take on the co-op cartoon shooter from a
talented two-person Studio let's dive
into the world of Enchanted portals yes
please
Peggy 12.
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
anyone else just get deja vu explore a
variety of animated Styles when
Enchanted portals comes to PC and
consoles later this year okay we've got
a dark fantasy deck building RPG up next
full of procedural Dungeons and
branching narrative choices let's check
in with shattered heaven
but an endless help
but this ends now destiny
thank you
it's ours to shape
you have no idea
shattered Heaven is out now on PC what's
up next Yuri uh okay well if I'm reading
this correctly then we're introducing
the fart Squad oh yeah you mean the
furniture Arrangement and relocation
technicians great house movers to have
on speed dial
are those with
and those who carry stuff away when your
stuff needs moving it's time to call
smooth moves
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
would you mind like giving me the number
for the fart Squad after we wrap
of course I love those guys moving out
too is coming soon
next up we've got our ones to watch
segment a montage of some of the coolest
indie games on the horizon
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
that was our ones to watch Montage if
anything caught your eye you can find
out more on these games and everything
else in the show by heading to our
dedicated steam page which you can find
by searching for future game show on
Steam the Montage but now it's time to
take a look at warhaven nexons free to
play 16 vs 16 fantasy brawler
broken
[Music]
foreign
is coming in Fall 2023. be sure to wish
listed on Steam as you'll be able to
play warhaven during steam nextfest
later this month steam steam steam steam
steam steam steam steam steam steam I
feel like we've said that word a lot
lately yeah looks like we're living in a
steam world at this point and we're just
we're steam butts you know mining and
flooring building houses for the steamed
folk I am a steam wait what
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
steam World build is coming to PC
Playstation Xbox and Nintendo switch in
2023 make sure it's on your steam World
wish lists if you like what you saw
now Erie you've heard of nightmares
right but what about a day mayor
sounds even worse somehow maybe in
concept but not in our next game which
is a third person survival horror that's
nostalgic for the 90s
you must be important if he brought you
here instead of just killing you it
can't be some knowledge is Best Kept
hidden from the rest of the world Grace
you should stay out of this you think
you understand but you're blind like
everyone else
you need to get out of here right now
they all seem to become obsessed with
the same thing you can't betrayed us
that data can't be allowed to leave here
the living and the dead have contributed
with their lives or the whole world will
burn
stop
I'm going to finish this forever
rest now
stay frosty because daymare is coming to
Playstation Xbox and PC on August 30th
2023 so prime those wish listing fingers
folks what's next Laura we're gonna
throw it over to core engage the team
behind news cycle a diesel Punk City
Builder that takes place after a
devastating solar flare
[Music]
thank you
that was new cycle which is coming to PC
in Q2 2023
you know what to do people
we've got another world premiere now and
it also features trade but not in the
way you think check it out
Once Upon a Time
there was a happy place called Riverside
and right there there was a bear called
the roughy yeah no one could tell why
but ruffy had this amazing ability to
swap things yeah really we just swapped
them and it was easy for him grab it
[Applause]
forwards
there you go
swap just about anything but his job had
him swap paintings for townspeople I've
been pays Suave you name it life was
perfect
until one day a long forgotten evil
emerged out of the darkness the
devastation came all over Riverside and
the end was near
now it was up to ruffy to accept his
Destiny and swap the bad father
[Music]
did you see that swap body are you
sloppy enough to save the world
[Music]
that was easy
things might get rough but you are rough
here
and you will never swap alone
[Music]
swapping to PC and Nintendo switch this
winter yeah correct this winter the oh
whenever it's ready
[Music]
hey every brand needs a mascot and I
think we just found ours ruffy in the
Riverside is barreling its way onto PC
and Nintendo switch this winter so get
it on your wish list now our next
section is a slight change of pace this
year we'll start to get our hands on the
first games developed in Unreal Engine
five but we wanted to show you a glimpse
of what games in 2024 25 and Beyond
might look like expect startling Tech
demos and Cutting Edge Vistas as we give
you a glimpse of the future of games
wait what at the future game show
outrageous precisely
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and that was the inaugural Unreal Engine
5 showcase and a warning to graphics
cards everywhere I can hear mine
squealing and bursting into flames from
here be sure to head over to the fgs
social channels if you want to see more
unreal 5 demos as and when they drop and
while you do that I am pleased to report
the sighting of a friendly neighborhood
World premiere oh come on let's see it
then
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Studios for that face melting first look
at fretless the wrath of rifson which is
coming to PC in 2024. another double
feature up next focusing on Hammer Watch
2 and paleo Pines Laura I am pleased to
report that it is once again
dinosaur time yes
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
paleo Pines is coming on September 26th
and Hammer Watch 2 is coming soon stick
them on your wish lists and watch out
for the demos for both games which will
be available on Steam from June 19th
speaking of demos our ones to play
montage is back after its debut in the
spring showcased earlier this year
don't touch that dial as we're going to
show off a bunch of incredible games
that you can try right after the show
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I'm not dial here
[Music]
thank you
thank you to all of the amazing
developers who submitted their demos for
our ones to play montage and remember
you can check them all out by heading to
our dedicated future game show steam
page we're taking a quick break from the
trailers now to deliver an exciting
update in last year's summer showcase we
were proud to feature a selection of
amazing games being created by Ukrainian
developers under exceptional conditions
this year we're thrilled to confirm the
release date for one of those games
right now puzzles for clef is a cozy
puzzle platformer set in a stunning
world full of magic and mystery and it's
coming to Nintendo switch and PC via
Steam on July 27th go check it out you
can also head to our fgs social channels
for more updates on the games from
Ukraine that we featured during last
year's show okay time for another
trailer we've got a first look at
gameplay from Station to Station a
wholesome simulator where you connect
voxel Railways to build thriving cities
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
ah not a super villain in sight I think
I could do with some tranquil train time
actually Station to Station is coming to
PC in 2023 and a demo is available right
now so go check it out after the show
next up we're taking a step into the
world of fantasy with Ember storm
entertainment's atmospheric base Builder
Recca
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
don't forget to pack your boots as Rekha
delightful chicken Cottage included is
coming to PC in 2024. okay our friends
at Sega have got a new trailer to share
regarding Company of Heroes 3. let's
check it out
[Music]
Company of Heroes 3 is coming to
PlayStation and Xbox on May 30th
thank you Yuri but I've got a feeling
this next game is gonna be a good one
wait a second is that you
'll be free in a role-playing Musical
wait wait wait wait
and we're about to be introduced to the
main romanceable characters oh my God
bring me my popcorn somebody get me some
popcorn please
[Music]
ah who's this crazy why does he have
horns I've been known most often as a
pan
I know where you belong
[Applause]
[Music]
you still aren't telling me something
good how can you even stand him still
not a fan honestly he's exactly what I'd
expect him to be what about Apollo
Apollo was God of the Sun and light but
our Sun God had a reputation
[Music]
thank you
all alone
it'll always say what did I do
what side are you on I said I would just
make things worse and I was right do you
trust him I'm not sure I think so famous
last words
tell me what you know about Persephone
honestly she's the least like her
stories are you here to challenge me you
don't know the first thing about me
because you're so big and scary I'm glad
you appreciate my finer qualities I like
this better than fighting with you way
better why didn't you tell me what it
was really all about we all have our
sorted history it just sounds a little
volatile they're always looking out for
me Freddy that's the deal right best
friends to the end it's an adventure
wow that was awesome and to celebrate
Laura has promised to perform a wrap
from the game for us no I haven't are
you sure yes I'm sure
not happening anyway I'm so pleased to
be able to reveal that as well as PC
straight guards is coming to Xbox
PlayStation and Nintendo switch on
August 3rd 2023. hey if you're in it and
Rahul Kohli is in it I'm playing it and
now that we've got that out of our
system it's time for me to introduce a
new section to the show one that I'm
calling the international debut
it's another world premiere isn't it
okay fine but you have to spoil it
[Music]
laughs
that reminds me of home
[Music]
this game
again
[Music]
that was your first look at reveal I
love horror games but our next game is
all about driving to survive in an
anomaly-filled exclusion Zone here's
Ironwood Studios with a developer
presentation about what to expect in
Pacific Drive
initially it was very much a personal
thing you know I grew up driving station
wagons around the Pacific Northwest I
would go camping I'd go to the beach I'd
go on road trips with friends and as an
adult I decided to start doing that
again so I you know I got an old station
wagon and I started going out on these
trips but you know I would go to
abandoned industrial sites I would go
you know taking the car up these tiny
little dirt trails and there was this
you know Vibe this feeling of being out
there in the woods with this old car a
very surreal experience and that became
I think the initial seat idea for the
game
Drive is a run-based driving Survival
game but when we started we were very
much just prototyping we were getting
the player into the car having them
drive around to the woods and getting a
feel of the space out there what we
quickly figured out is there's a lot of
overlap between resource management kind
of plate juggling that you wanted a good
survival game and taking care of a car
like
making sure that you don't run out of
gas and checking on your battery it all
eventually came to fruition with the
garage and US figuring out we wanted a
safe space for the player to be the
mechanic and to work on their car and
taking these excursions out into the
Zone where you're grabbing resources and
exploring and then coming back and being
able to do it again in most survival
games there's a focus on the player in
keeping them alive but for Pacific drive
we wanted to trim that on its head a bit
and put the emphasis on the car it's the
thing that's going to keep you safe when
you're out in the zone but that's only
true so long as you maintain it the
player can still take damage but the car
itself is is a good deal more
complicated there's different slots that
you can put different equipment into and
customize your car but things may happen
to those parts they may take wear and
tear they may get damaged and break or
fall off in which case you may have to
craft replacement parts or scavenge for
new things out in the zone we really
care about satisfying that fantasy of
the player being a mechanically just
taking care of this car maintaining it
while they're on the road it's important
for us to do this because that that
interaction helps build the player's
relationship with the car and that's
something that we care a lot about
so the zone is a pretty isolating and
lonely place when you're out on the road
your car is your only real travel
company and we wanted to make sure the
players have the ability to build a
personal connection with the card that
is special to them we've also doubled
down on that with the physical
interactions as well so every time you
want to start the car you have to turn
the key you have to get the engine to
start you have to put it in park
manually we built the whole game with
these systems in mind because we want to
create
effectively a Sandbox for these
different Dynamic moments to occur
sometimes when I'm driving the car I
find I have to Swerve suddenly just to
get out the way of a saw blade or an
electrical anomaly and then I'm on my
side in the woods and that's actually
that's fine though because the first
time I drove into the woods was as a
teenager going about 40 miles an hour
but that's another story I spent an
eternity climbing the super super steep
hill with my car I finally got to the
top climb out of my car to get what I'm
going after and turn around and they're
a broken bunnies just sticking all over
it they slammed on the gas it's in a
barrel right back down the hill there
was a time that I came around a corner
and drifted too hard onto a cliff and
rolled straight down the cliff and
actually ran into a group of abductors
and one of them pulled me straight into
the gateway and I made a safe exit from
there even though the storm was closing
in
I think the experience I'm looking
forward to players having the most is
gaining that sense of companionship with
the car you know sitting in the garage
looking at it seeing all of these
stories that have happened to Crazy
escapes the last minute repair jobs and
really to feel like it's their car I
think that's going to be something
really special
good
foreign
Pacific Drive is coming to PC and PS5
later this year and to celebrate we're
giving away these custom built station
wagon one of you lucky viewers could be
driving home in style tonight wait a
minute Yuri that's literally the car
from the game you can't give that away I
think they're going to need it back
of course I mean I I knew that yeah yeah
you knew you knew so let's just
come on while the producers put out some
fires I'm the fire aren't I you really
are cookie cutter is up next a techno
pop punk metroidvania starring a badass
Android
my name is Cherry I'm different than
that mass produce junk
I was built to entertain my Creator
lately I can't understand what I feel
anymore
[Music]
they will pay for what they deter
thank you
cookie cutter is coming to PC in 2023 so
head on over to the steam page and hit
that wish list button okay it's World
premiere time again and fans of the
classic top down GTA games might get a
kick out of this one
[Applause]
[Music]
bank robbery in progress
handling responding code three
thank you
the leaves are engaged in a dramatic
piece
[Music]
foreign
the precinct is a crime-fighting action
Sandbox game set in the 1980s basically
everything that I love and it's coming
to PC PlayStation and Xbox and 2024. and
with that it's time for our final
trailer of the night
I know those of you who tuned into last
year's summer showcase you may remember
Ludo broken Bird games terrifying
psychological Thriller about a person
trapped in their own home it's a little
bit PT a little bit eat a finch time for
an update don't you think I do
Peggy 18.
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that was a brand new look at Ludo which
is coming soon to PC PlayStation and
Xbox so make sure it's on your wish
lists you can also check out the free
demo for the game on Steam that looks
like the end of the show folks thank you
so much for tuning in it has been so fun
wait a second Yuri now my spidey sense
is tingling wait what you mean like fgs
specific World premieres spidey sense I
think so I think that's what this is I
guess that means there's one more thing
then let's see it
I'm going to tell you a story a story
about three extraordinary Spirits United
to face the darkness
[Music]
thank you
three incredible Warriors defying fate
and even death
I Kitsune
Spirit of the forest was a witness and a
part of it
[Applause]
that was the spirit of the Samurai a
stop-motion Adventure inspired by
Japanese mythology get it on your wish
lists as it's coming in 2024. well it's
safe to say this has been a blast for me
anyway thank you so much for being my
partner in voice acting crime fighting
and now show hosting Laura oh you're so
welcome yerry anytime
literally anytime you want it back okay
okay to our audience thank you so much
for tuning in we really appreciate it
also a big shout out to our sponsor
Intel and everybody who worked to make
the summer showcase a reality remember
that you can find and wish list every
game seen in today's show on the
dedicated future game show steam page
this is where you'll find all of the
demos too just Google future game show
steam you can also read more about each
game on gamesradar.com and see extra
content from our editorial team on the
dedicated fgs social channels I'm Yuri
lowenthal and I'm Laura Bailey and this
is this has been the future game show
summer showcase 2023
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]